left wing Canadian Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
is a embroiled in a bit of a scandal after
some pictures went public of him wearing black
face when he was in his late twenties.
In one picture, Trudeau is wearing very, very
dark makeup on his entire face.
And neck at an Arabian themed nights party
at the West Point Grey Academy where he was
teaching at the time.
There was another picture in which Trudeau
is wearing a less extreme version of the black
face during a high school talent show in which
he sang a Jamaican folk song.
So let's discuss this.
Conservatives obviously are just falling all
over themselves to attack the left of being
hypocrites.
Oh, when a right wing or wears black face,
they have to be destroyed according to the
left.
But when a left winger wears black face, it's
no big deal.
Now, of course, this just isn't true.
My analysis is the same on black face, no
matter who did it.
I don't care if it's Megan Kelly defending
blackface or Justin Trudeau wearing black
face or whatever the case may be.
It's not okay.
Black face has a horrible racist past.
You can debate, oh, it's for comedy or whatever.
And then we get into that conversation about
what can just be excused away.
It being for comedic purposes, but there's
no ifs, ands, or buts about it.
It doesn't matter who did it.
Black faces not okay.
The differences start to show up, not in our
analysis, but in the person who did its reaction
to the black face and Justin Trudeau has immediately
apologized with no caveats, period.
Not, I apologize if anybody was offended.
Right?
That bull.
You know what it is that bs thing, I'm almost
forgot I was on a broadcast radio and TV there,
that bs thing about if anyone was offended,
I apologize.
Justin Trudeau saying, quote, I shouldn't
have done that.
I should have known better and I didn't.
I'm really sorry.
This is what's called a real apology.
When he was asked if he thought that the photograph
was racist, he said yes it was.
I didn't consider it racist at the time, but
now we know better.
So one set of very clear differences between
some l some instances of blackface and other
instances of blacks face.
Is the reaction from the person involved or
the person commenting?
You might remember former Fox News host and
is she former NBC?
Has she completely been let go from NBC or
is she just in a reduced role?
Megan Kelly said on that really wacky daytime
NBC show she had for a little while.
What's the big deal with black face anyway?
Sort of like reminiscing nostalgically about
the era of black face that is very different
from Justin Trudeau saying this was wrong.
Even if I didn't recognize it as racist at
the time.
It's racist.
No excuses.
I'm sorry.
So that is one major difference.
Number two, I do believe that it matters when
the person can credibly say this was a mistake,
black faces racist, but there's no link whatsoever
to my policies as an elected official versus
a politician who was not only caught wearing
blackface but also supports racist policies,
has a history of saying racist things, whatever.
So it's not about you know the what if the
person is on the left.
We treat them differently than if the person
is on the right.
It's just wrong.
It's wrong period.
And there should be apologies with no caveats
whatsoever.
But there is a difference between someone
who defends having worn black face and perpetuates
racist policies versus someone who doesn't
and says it was completely wrong.
Now, either way, this is not good for Justin
Trudeau.
There's no question about that.
He actually has sort of what I think of as
a bigger scandal.
Uh, that could be an impediment to his reelection
in October's a Canadian election, which is
that he is accused of having pressured a prosecution
to be dropped, which would be really, really
bad.
And by the way, the timing of the black face
thing, clearly someone had this for a long
time.
These were not pictures that were buried in
some way and not available.
Clearly the, the timing of the release has
been calculated.
It doesn't make the black face anything different
than what it is, which is wrong, not a defense
of the black face, but this isn't a yearbook
that's been around forever.
Clearly this could have come out anytime and
the timing, just literally a month ahead of
the October 21st Canadian elections.
We'll see what effect it has and we will follow
a, what happens with our friendly neighbors
to the north.